halo is filling in the backstory for
master chief seemingly connecting him to
the covenant more than anyone expected
meanwhile a fan favorite character makes
her entrance in a way that may prove
controversial spoilers ahead for halo
season 1 episode 2.
in halo's first episode audiences were
introduced to a legendary spartan super
soldier known as master chief and quanha
a 16 year old orphan who suddenly finds
herself the target of a sizable
intergalactic bounty last we saw them
the newly acquainted traveling
companions were forced to fly away from
the united nations space command
headquarters without a clue of a plan
for where to go next
[Music]
episode 2 introduces an important
character from master chief's past and
gives us new insight on the mysterious
covenant relic that appears so uniquely
tied to master chief it also teases the
introduction of a fan favorite character
whose portrayal could prove somewhat
divisive among fans of the halo video
game series
let's dive into episode 2 of halo and
the biggest takeaways from the second
hour of the series
as master chief and quan ha seek refuge
from the reach of unsc the two visit the
rubble a civilization built within the
confines of a series of hollowed-out
asteroids here the duo are welcomed by
the society's leader sorin a former unsc
training buddy of master chiefs and a
man who also happens to offer unique
insight into the mysterious covenant
relic after providing master chief in
kwan with food and shelter soren
introduces the two to ref one of a
handful of people who has experience
living in the covenant as one might
expect even in the 25th century being
kidnapped by aliens leaves wrath with a
visibly loose grip on the world however
he is quick to recognize the importance
of the object because his touch does not
activate the device as master chiefs
does wrath refers to master chief as a
blessed one what's a blessed one human
only immortal after confirming that
master chief does not have any plans to
destroy the human race wrath forces the
device into master chief's hands once
more just as it did in episode 1 the
device suddenly emits an expanding ring
of light and triggers a flurry of
childhood memories within the spartan
breath later explains that the device is
a covenant weapon a realization that
master chief admits he recognized but
never voiced perhaps most interestingly
reth insists that master chief must
destroy the artifact and himself in
order to protect life as we know it the
entire exchange proves quite revelatory
for master chief leading him to quickly
return to unsc headquarters on reach
meanwhile kwon catches up with the
situation back on matrical taquan's
shock and horror the planet's power
vacuum has allowed a rebel traitor named
venture graf to take over her home
planet as soren puts it venture is
cleaning house on madrigal from the
comfort of the rubble kwan watches drone
footage of venture executing a variety
of political dissidents leaving her in
tears quan explains that venture and her
father often quarreled over how to
respond to the threat posed by the unsc
although she insists she only wants
justice for her father and the rest of
her people it quickly becomes clear that
development on her home planet are going
to be a major issue for her even after
master chief departs the rubble for the
unsc quan is shown watching footage of
venture's rise to power with a searing
hatred for her father's former enemy
interestingly venture speech references
a historic deal made with the unsc in an
attempt to return madrigal to its place
as the gem of the outer colonies which
suggests yet another potential
complication for her grudging alliance
with master chief
elsewhere upon his return to reach
master chief expresses a wish to discuss
his memories but dr catherine halsey
isn't having it saying it's not a
constructive place to go notably halsey
and her colleagues have previously
indicated fear of master chief regaining
his childhood memories much of master
chief's discussion with halsey also
focuses on the question of the spartan's
own identity as master chief explains
the feelings he has recently developed
we see the covenant loyal blessed one
maki disrobe and reveal an interesting
set of scars on her back of course while
we don't completely understand the
reason for this combination of scenes it
certainly seems obvious that a
connection between the two blessed ones
is being suggested
after master chief explains his
motivation for returning to the unsc so
quickly halsey thanks him for coming
back saying i see this as a new
beginning we're going to do great things
together as halsey says these words the
series again cuts to a different scene
in which halsey is shown awakening a
clone of herself it's heavily suggested
that this clone is related to an
advanced artificial intelligence of her
design called cortana
cortana is the next stage in human
evolution of course halo video game fans
will recognize cortana as the name of
the legendary artificial intelligence
who guides master chief on his missions
while cortana may be introduced as an
actual physical person in the tv series
it seems clear that she won't remain
that way for long also given the fact
that the clone was activated prior to
master chief's interrogation can we be
sure that master chief is actually
talking to the real halsey in this final
scene the truth is not quite clear even
by its second episode halo is full of
mysteries even for people who played all
the games new episodes of halo drop on
paramount plus every thursday
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]